[Music]
Samuel leaves here hope you've had a
fantastic day or are having and today
we're gonna be talking about how great
we won't be important investor but what
are we actually borrowing wherever the
goldmine areas to buy what do we buy
hmmm stimulants what's the best strategy
so if that sounds I give you useful
stick around for the next 10 minutes or
so and here goes most people who buy
property investments do it completely
wrong and that is because they buy with
their feelings they say oh this looks
very pretty
unlike the garden all the neighbors were
so nice I like the area and then find a
bit their feelings I mean I had a lady
who said to me just a few months ago
I've just bought a proper chested great
where is it she said oh it's in Bristol
I said cool why Bristol well because my
son's moving to University in Bristol
and shoot me in the face
don't try and kill two birds don't are
the feelings it's completely the wrong
thing to do you'll end up okay you might
still make money because property is
very lucrative but you'll leave a lot of
money on the table so instead of buying
with feelings instead you need to buy
with formulas you need to understand how
to work out the return on investment you
need to be saying how much profit how
much cash is this deal gonna generate me
yes I don't care about the garden yes I
don't care about the fact that there's
whatever you know the bottom line is
most of the houses that I've bought I
haven't even seen with my own eyes
before buying them now you might think
that's crazy
don't worry I have sent someone out to
look at them but the bottom line is I
don't care about this that the other
people say it has to be nearby my house
why does it have to be nearby your house
because if there's a problem then I can
step in and sort it out guess what
that's caught a rope around your neck
not
financial freedom guess what you have a
bunch of houses but you'll actually have
a hundred headaches because unless you
fight with formulas and systems you'll
never be financially free yes you might
make money down the long term but this
is all about formulas systems so that is
what this video is about so in that case
or what are these formulas what I'm
talking about
the important thing is that you know how
to work out the return on investment
people bring me all the time
deal sauces and packages and people like
that they're with me
mr. leaves we've got a very interesting
footage I think you absolutely love
awesome what's the return on investment
oh well actually they're building a
train station nearby the area ok cool
what's the return on investment oh and
also there actually there's an airport
nearby and there's expected to be a lot
of capital appreciation over the next 12
to 18 months I've got a very small box
and I haven't got time for stories could
you just give me the return on
investment please Oh 12%
not interested 50% not interested
18% not interested hang up thank you
what while I'm being such a douche about
all this well the bottom line is because
of this people estate agents deal
sources family friends everybody will
try and get you to buy with your
feelings they're not doing then they'll
get always emotionally charged questions
and you know what it doesn't matter this
is what matters
return on investment can you work that
out you need two sons two calculations
to work this out one is what's your
investment what are you putting in to
the deal that might be that you're not
putting anything into the deal because
you've structured it in a clever way
which means that you'll be getting an
infinite return on investments what are
you putting in and I need you together
and you can work out your return on
investment hope that makes sense
you
if you if you get into the habit of just
buying based on your on the return on
investment you're going to suddenly stop
making a lot more cash flow and you'll
get financially free a whole lot quicker
so let me give you a little case study
on the last house that I bought was a
two-bedroom house and I paid fifty six
thousand pounds for it now that's not
how much I invest it because that's just
the purchase price I actually invest it
I had to put out a deposit typically you
deposit about 20 25 percent it depends
on you in the house and how good your
broker is oh I actually put 25 percent
which is 14 thousand pounds so that's
more investment on top of that you've
got your legal fees and your stamp duty
stamp duties a bit of a pain but you
know what where the rules recently
changed okay about stamp duty and they
said that you've got to pay 3% stamp
duty on any house you buy pretty much
they're always around it but we're not
going to go into that today
now everybody that's crazy the days of
property investing or rather than the
government are trying to screw you and
the tax changes and that this another
and the other all I'm going to say right
now because some of this will come at a
later stage and some of the videos
perhaps or will say right now is this
one right now I think is the best time
to invest in property than it has been
in a very long time
number two is that whenever a rule
changes for the bat over here it changes
for the good over here and there's
always a loophole or a way around the
problem reason being is because the
people the people that make up the rules
people that invest in property yeah tree
the true story I mean the Queen has got
I think a 15 million pound property
portfolio so so don't worry if you're
being made up by naysayers that's fine
you've got two types of people one
person will think of a reason why not to
do something and the other will think of
a reason why to do something one
Brooklands rich okay so that's about how
it is
114 grams pullers I put down establish
et legal fees the property did any work
doing it whatsoever so that can Lance
what it was about 2000 they're about to
keep the math simple which means that
16,000 pounds was my total investment
that figure we want to know about now
will rub out the workings because we
don't really care about them right now
people say well what's the market value
below market value was it it's not that
important if you're getting a really
high return on investment even if you
played a hundred percent market value
does it really matter so sixteen grams
that's your investment how much do I get
back well migraines and I'm a sitting
tenant so on in the property already
that wants to stay forever paying five
hundred and fifty pounds per month now
my mortgage payments which are fixed for
five years when mortgage payments cost
eighty pounds per month
now I'm no great mathematician but I am
profit here yeah absolutely
what other costs have you got when
you're buying a property very little
insurance is about 15 pounds a month and
my management fees that I pay 10% is 55
per month so you know I'm making quite a
bit of profit let's just be really
conservative and say I'm making a profit
of 400 pounds per month times that my 12
and that will come down to 4,800 so
these are the two things that I care
about I care about 16 grand I care about
4,800 what I care about those two
because I need to work out the return on
investment if you divide those two by
each other that will then give you your
return on investment which in this case
works out to be
thirty percent return on investment so I
put down 16 grand and after three and a
bit years I've made my full money back
the property is gone up in value and
I've got an extra four thousand eight
hundred pounds a year coming in passive
income I've only got to knock that up to
my expenses and I'm completely
financially free so that is just a
little example where was this property
this property was actually in
Middlesbrough now Middlesbrough is about
four hours from my house but you know
what it doesn't matter that's all I care
about these figures now if I had to do a
big reefer on the property I'd have to
factor that into my figures another type
of property which I invest in which work
out really really well
ah hm oh what a HMO is is you'd have
normally that a property might be a
3-bit house you might either house four
hundred thousand pounds and rent the
house out or seven hundred pounds a
month which is going to leave you the
profit of about after your your mortgage
payments and stuff maybe 500 550 a month
which is not bad give you a return of
perhaps fifteen percent return on
investment great HMO is effective love
oil we do is we've got our reception
rooms you've got a kitchen and bathroom
outdoor wide so what we do is we rent
the property out on a room by room basis
so rather than getting 700-pound we get
three fifth day because that's how much
you pay times three but we convert one
of the reception rooms into a bedroom
now to convert a reception room into a
bedroom is going to take a little bit of
doing you know you're gonna need
building range you're gonna need an
architect and there's a bit of money
behind you because in
reception room in your bedroom what you
have to do is you have to put a bed in
it it's really quite straightforward
people will massively overcomplicate
each amount they'll make it sound really
difficult or really scary talk about you
know you need this rags all this all a
license for this kind of procurement you
do not need a license you do not need
rags you know your Planning Commission
as long as you part in the right area so
350 times four is suddenly 1400 so you
doubled your amount of rent now you are
going to have some costs for HMOs
admittedly there's still your return on
investments gonna go up quite a bit so
again hateoas or a fantastic investment
what about if you haven't got the five
months behind you well we're gonna go
into that on the next video so hopefully
now one you've got your foundational
thinking and you understand that this is
about passive income it's about buying a
box that gives you return on investment
properties are supposed to be assets as
Robert Kiyosaki said so eloquently the
house you live in is not an asset the
definition of an asset is something that
puts money into your back pocket every
single month so the better the asset it
means this we giving you more money in
your back pocket so rather than thinking
all these questions about where is it
what's it look like
and always forget it how good of an
asset is it what's the return on
investment so this is just a little
taster of what to buy hope it's been
helpful I did promise to talk to a
little bit about areas so I'll give you
a quick summary on my thoughts on what
areas are good okay remember this write
down if needs be as the recession comes
expansion after expansion comes
recession not to think so is naive
generally speaking in this country 2008
we had a big recession which means that
on the way is a big expansion now London
leads and everywhere else follows London
2008 boom recession but then it followed
everywhere
you probably remember this this is when
I started I started out around 2008 so
what's happened in London well we saw it
from 2008 2011
in 2012 those four years it was terrible
big recession befallen spread across the
whole country however what happened
around about 2011-2012 in London while
the market picked up in fact in the last
sort of six years in London properties
have rocketed some of them have even
doubled in value some parts of London
they've gone crazy now right now the
London is quite static at the moment
however that has now followed on to
Birmingham and Wolverhampton and parts
of the area which is where a few years
ago I was investing in Birmingham I was
interested in water handsome because and
what's happened well a couple - three
years back I invested in those areas I
even helped others do the same myself
and some of my students off we done
we've made tens of thousands some people
hundreds of thousands of pounds in the
caps and appreciation in the Midlands
what's now going to happen a bit further
afield up north well of course the same
thing is gonna happen again there are
properties up north in areas like Paul
Bradford Doncaster Middlesbrough where
the values haven't gone up they haven't
recovered at all in ten years some parts
of the Sun some parts of the north the
properties are cheaper now than they
were in 2008 there's a good opportunity
not only can you get really good return
from some of the cheaper areas but the
expansion is coming so be excited I hope
you our next video is going to be about
how to buy properties with no money and
if you bother if you've not met me in
person
I do do property investors crash courses
I like suggest check it out right here
boom hope it came up again and get
yourself down it was really good to meet
you in person
[Music]
you